welcome to this video playing
international master Stephane dachshund
again yeah let's see I want to do
something non theoretical before a
change let's see what happens and I had
a Ben Oni last time and somehow it
didn't didn't work out so let's do let's
do something else okay I can't play d5
no which I which I will do why not take
the center oh yeah I know I love the
temple yeah but okay and so it's a
misplaced Bishop on b7 maybe you can do
something crazy it was b5 but I don't
don't believe it so this is also kind of
a Benoni but with a weird weird bishop
there 27 okay yeah let's let's prepare
the normal development with before
therefore
22 and everything nicely centralized
yeah should I go to d2 not clear
yeah maybe shouldn't think it's so long
here one problem is that for him a
meanness that I'm really really nicely
centralized I wonder if I should play
for before maybe rugby one can he play
b5 maybe at some point here and I would
the e4 pawn being being under pressure
okay and start with a for making sure
that b5 is not coming easily maybe then
try to opt for a before idea he goes b5
no I can take and play before which is
really nice ok that's it's very nice for
white kind of the Bologna dream position
many good ideas Knight d4 also also
tempting 94 27 know what you can also
put the bishop to d4
look a $1 is this there's a little bit
little bit too meek maybe I'm not sure
and I don't want to fall too far behind
on time
not easier it's very nice but not so
easy to to find a way forward maybe I
can actually queen bee to and keep the
look away
like blackulas cannot do very much
I'm always pressurizing B 5 D 6 and so
on but it's still not so easy to to find
a way to really put it away I was
thinking maybe Bishop f3 Queen B - okay
one this kind of business getting rid of
the active rook thank you he's going
voluntarily in a way just putting this
back okay yeah oh just how do I get
ahead here rook a one rook a five maybe
I mean if I was really securely
protected with the bishop now on f3 and
rook a seven is also on the okay this is
probably good
now this looks like good control between
a7 or queen a5 is coming I could have
just taken b5 of course I was thinking
yes to pre move Bishop a8 anyway that
was stupid
my okay yes he does not really have a
good move now but 97 maybe okay so I can
just take it here right
hey just this looks like a total win I
mean I mean I'm really good at screwing
up those things but it looks it looks
really good for white okay if I take
this and play queen 87 now don't don't
tell me that there is some some sort of
counter play no I thought nice deform
and then in there somehow is this bishop
teef was also good here getting on the
non-diagonal preventing Bishop g7 in the
first place yeah and now how to win this
I'm total control here so maybe just
just get the Queen over to the Kings
side yes like here
Queen to g5 Queen to f4 three G for
coming and the bishop to f6 if he goes
Bishop c8 this Bishop f6 well that looks
good check
check check check
I'm just picking up on yet
that's really really enough not not much
more
I think about it for a moment
I can also attack these six yeah that's
not a bad idea he cannot defend it this
is running into a self-penned probably
probably not check check check check
check black it's on time well okay I
made it somewhat interesting no from
this really winning position but I
really have a bad score against the sky
some a little bit a little bit a little
bit nervous that maybe I don't know yeah
this was really I mean also bit
surprised how easily he got into this
because here this is almost a
strategical win for white I mean this is
very very nice
with b5 being weak and black has really
no count and play I think when I managed
to trade off the ropes we got to a
really great position and here of course
I can just take b5 but that was pretty
moving Queen e2 basically and I didn't
really it was giving away
again here there are there multiple ways
to windward check at least I never
totally screwed it up
yeah you fibers even stronger with
occasion and canvas is totally winning
so it's it's okay I mean I was also a
little bit ahead on the clock so no
problem then in converting okay good to
have this winning thanks for watching